what are you training for so your
trailer you actually train them for this
fight under you you just you just did a
fight low yeah I had a fight last year
August 25th and then yeah another
another one this year November 9th same
same kid it's the rematch
okay on two so professional fight no
headgear Staples Center it's gonna be
sick man and you guys think you'll sell
it out I think so
wow I think so that's crazy it's a big
fight to hold the whole undercard is
professional fights yeah it's the first
view it's like your first professional
yeah fine
yeah oh really yeah London crazy I'm
gonna feed it so far I'm all in one bro
I beat your brother's ass for years to
didn't you ha we stopped because we both
got him yeah man he's big dude like kids
a thick little Oreo yeah yeah so so we
gotta stop fighting because we destroy
everything yeah you know in the house
right well the brothers get so big that
they'll destroy everything right I say a
chairs tables glass so we stop so it's
been a minute since I was and he's got a
little bit of Flintstone in him to a
little more than he does man you know
he's that I noticed and you [ __ ]
couldn't tell if he was like 19 or own
like 38 you know yeah the hair doesn't
give it away oh just like the high and
tight for years but I think he I don't
know what it was he just has he reminds
me of every guy who owns like a nice
boat in Florida that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah wasn't everything where he was
gonna fight someone to you were gonna do
it and there wasn't your dad gonna fight
somebody so we [ __ ] yet yeah dude the
whole family's gonna fight dude I hope
your dad fights that old or black guy
he's like uh uh he's a politician but
he's like from he can't even talk and
everybody's like he's the best and he's
like my dad Jesse's smaller I think
that'd be a great mean gping jesse small
it just dude that was only minutes
phenomenal yeah your dad would probably
take care of that man he would me I mean
dude who knows go on his Instagram
you'll see all this man does yeah he's
chop wood and tie tomahawks to his
motorcycle yeah that's all he's small it
no not my dad he flips tires he chops
wood he ties tomahawks to his beers I
think Jesse Smollett beat your dad you'd
have to kill your father I oh yeah oh
yeah put in ever
look at your fall no I know that it
couldn't you know there's no Christmas
is over
everything's yeah yeah if Jessie ones
yeah that's why it's all that just he's
smaller I can't believe if he fought
your dad yeah I think like it
historically he's not so good at
defending himself right that's true
right yeah yeah your dad way I think
your honor honestly dude I have no idea
look like and I think he would be yeah
yeah I agree yeah but a lot of I'm
afraid of his dad oh noes dad I'm afraid
most people are afraid I that would
raise you and your brother I think has
got to be insane that's a pen boy who
will kill someone yeah and I appreciate
it it's definitely a property owner yeah
it's a real deal guy yes you know the
real deal guy that's not a guy that's
not a music teacher didn't bring up
these two boys you know what I mean this
is a guy that likes match around a
little bit yeah made you go out and
light the world on fire yeah that owns a
bunch of coal oh no no this guy's not
there was no he didn't read poetry
before dinner you know got into it you
know yeah this guy who mom is probably
also somewhat taught right know mom's a
sweet hell mom sweet the exact knobs the
way just like a sweet okay if you even
look at his mom you hear an oven door
opening oh yeah I like a Long Island mom
that's I could also see that ya get
tough notion island [ __ ] sweetheart
sweetheart oh yeah and you guys are from
where Ohio Ohio yeah so the fight so
this is gonna be a real suitable this
fight go on to some like W like like
sanctioned card or what does that happen
yeah yeah yeah it's legit man Eddie
hurts promoting it he's that he's the
he's one of the biggest boxing promoters
in the world if not the biggest it's
gonna be on the disown app mmm-hmm
Daz in right shameless plug his own app
but yeah it's gonna be [ __ ] crazy get
a little throw a little one two one two
actually what for action what would be
different about this fight than the
first one you did and I didn't see the
first one I know it was like I had a
million streams I know that a million to
two million pirated every way crazy like
lost 20 million dollars in one night you
twenty million plus and why my crazy
[ __ ] sucks dude and were you getting
paid on buys and stuff or is that yeah
we were gonna pay to buy a time flat fee
because we did it through YouTube right
now to zone we have that there's own
bought the fight they bought the rights
to the fight the difference this time is
like yo last time I went in as a
youtuber who had to learn how to box in
like 3-4 months that's boxing is hard
boxing is not a sport you can just walk
into and rely on your athleticism to
make you do well which I which I did
right and I did okay but for the whole
past year I've been training like pretty
rigorously yeah so and so this time I'm
actually like I would consider myself a
fully fed vetted boxer
what is the regimen I wanna I want to
hear this you wake up yeah we wake up we
run we box how long do you hold on a
second hold on Tim who was we me and my
bro Oh your brother so your brother's
right there with you the whole time
sometimes he wasn't he wasn't today but
most of the time yeah and is that did is
that it just a commitment you guys made
is I think he's gonna fight on the
undercard I think he's gonna find on the
other undercard and he enjoys boxing
just like me like you hired a yoga
trainer and the personal trainer right
to me
boxing is just as effective workout wise
and it's a practical skill like I don't
I don't like picking up weight so I
haven't picked up a weight in two to
three years I just like yeah you look
good you sculpt yourself you feel good
but boxing not only the does all that
happen but like you know like but also
you can you might have to attack someone
well who knows sometime you don't like
you might have to attack them it is a
club restaurant
I'll never attack I'll never tell
antagonize hey hey listen you know who
whatever happens happens you might a do
it feel to have okay so you might
traffic do you have a train or two or
not I do yeah okay yeah his name's
Milton okay yeah and so you guys go out
with him and you guys are doing guys hit
the ring are you hitting the ring under
give a boxing ring at her locks ring in
my backyard yeah you seen I saw that so
you're hitting that every day every day
Wow so 5-mile run yeah yeah yeah yeah we
do about three three four right now but
we'll get up to the five months we're
two months out you know so if you if you
peek now we're [ __ ]
yeah you know right you gotta like you
gotta train and get the the spurts of
yeah exerting yourself and are you guys
blowing a lot of gas each other y'all
talking a lot of [ __ ] you and the other
guy it just gotten out do it it's just
gotten outside yesterday oh wow so we
hadn't we haven't really had a chance to
like to do it man I wish I could I wish
I could use your wit like I'm gonna I'm
gonna actually channel you Theo
because
I feel like I'd be able to hurt a lot of
good insults just aw dude no it's not
like each other is it like one of those
things I hate the kid really and use a
black kid from England that's not why I
hate them no no no I know I'm no wait I
see it now I see what you're doing
yeah so you're fighting for the white
race okay well what's his knee he's he's
like the biggest YouTube guy in England
right yeah he's yeah oh yes yeah he's
yeah yeah okay I didn't know I'd never
seen him I know his name's kr1
that's right yeah no one know I mean I'm
gonna be honest if you're in America
like you don't know who the kid is if we
don't well here's the thing first of all
if we like if we wanted to be in Britain
so bad we'd have stayed over there say
we our ancestors here so bad it was
going we got into a boat left there
people are like where are you going
we're like we don't even [ __ ] know
we're leaving we're out that imagine
it'd be you don't have enough gas to get
there you like yeah well [ __ ] yeah we'll
see what figure it out and got this we
got this barrel of pepper that's what we
need we got some spices and we're good
to go man this was our nutty so this is
so this is uh was the first bout hearing
him in the US as well no it wasn't it
was a Manchester Oh now la for a person
or home for our van you got it that's
what I'm saying it you did yeah do you
feel like the first one it was a draw it
was a drugs a tie man yeah it sucked do
you feel like it was a time I feel like
I wanted he looks like a guy he looks a
formidable opponent is it his picture
behind me yeah I think so yeah unless
that's what the [ __ ] you I mean bro
chaos one look at his face first look
how you how you gonna take that serious
yeah I would tell you I saw him in an
alley I would take it seriously you know
what I mean and that's just because if I
saw him in an alley I would be somewhat
threatened but how many men have you met
in alleys a lot but it's usually it's
usually a text first so just from out of
nowhere if I just saw those dreadlocks
it looks like a tarantula and dude I
think guys it's those locks don't other
most dread in him I think this is the
number that look is this like white girl
dreadlocks doctor looks like yeah to me
that this is what that pictures the
photographer was like okay now scrunch
your faces look tough yeah and that's
what happen I've seen tougher black
women at a bus stop in Baltimore
yeah yeah absolutely your next fight you
just fight black limit a bus stop in
Baltimore dude I saw this lady one time
sponsored by Popeyes new chick this lady
drinking a whole six-pack of baby for no
yeah there's gotta be some sort of
nutritional benefits that we don't know
about but that's great but by the way
that makes me think how good is formula
that's what I'm saying that's the other
thing is that just nice Nestle Quik yes
potentially for me so that's the guy
right there kay everyone man and was so
what do you feel like he's gonna be
training as hard as you do you feel yeah
oh yeah seriously oh yeah you do man I'm
not gonna lie man's a dog yeah I'll give
it to him okay yeah man's got heart he
works hard I work it's it's sick it's
say I want to fight somebody now do you
though because this [ __ ] is rigorous man
is violent yeah
you know how many times like it's fine
you get hit in the head before you
realize oh [ __ ] this is gonna have some
long-term repercussions oh wow so you're
saying you even noticed that just from
that fight I spell too sometimes yeah
like oh you too
I spell it some yellow t wo how did you
spell it correctly t oo you two I mean I
can't I don't know how many people I got
I got real beef with other than that one
kid right you know the British guy yeah
the British guy yeah I mean where does
that come from that beef is that she's
talking [ __ ] you guys are both online
yeah so it was it started off cool and
then it during the press conferences and
[ __ ] just he crossed the line I crossed
the line and it just got super toxic and
unhealthy and now here we are we want to
[ __ ] rip each other's heads off and it
okay do you feel like this is so this is
something you're doing now as far as
like fighting people I think so me I
mean yeah are you gonna do you think
you're gonna continue this I think so
Wow I think it's just do you think you
become a boxer like Al Anam I'm gonna do
MMA I wrestled in high school I was good
I placed a 5th in Ohio so like I still
write also that a lot of that is there
yeah right yeah it boxing is a little
limiting for many of the other YouTube
guys your social media guys doing stuff
like this
no one I'll tell you why well they're
[ __ ] no nope there are a hundred
times smarter than me yo think about it
I mean [ __ ] combat sports are dangerous
this is not healthy getting hit in the
head over and over again right what am i
some kind of [ __ ] the answers yes like
I'd like to believe that everyone else
is it's a combination of their smarter
and it's not worth it and they probably
don't want to work that hard because
that's hard work right right you know I
got it set like something's some screws
are missing it's for it's not just
beating somebody up is a legit yeah we
have to train you and you're gonna loot
like um do you feel like you're gonna
kind of create a new fan base with some
of this too low for sure oh for sure
that's why stuff will change yeah that's
why I do I noticed in the last fight the
last fight after we did it I was
instantly elevated from youtube star to
like whatever the the level right right
below like traditional celebrity and
YouTube star like whatever's in between
that decide you're no you're a boldface
name people know yeah yeah yeah you know
you walk in somewhere it's not like oh
that's the guy that makes YouTube videos
like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] knows how
to fight and it's it's a different level
of respect and the [ __ ] game is huge I
love fighting my new UFC forever but you
Judith oh yeah yeah man it's huge and
it's growing and it's like what's gonna
be next like and this could be it
you know seeing people actually get to
you know talk [ __ ] but also back it up
if they want to in the rave maybe man
because the online [ __ ] talking is
there's never really been a place for
Coleman nobody goes and organizes a
fight between Rosie O'Donnell and post
POW they should be fighting each other
you know someone's gonna do it 100%